hey I'm Dean Peterson the filmmaker from
Brooklyn I made the film incredibly
small and I'm about to shoot my second
feature film what children do when we
shot my first film we shot it on the
Sony ex1
on prime lenses with a lettuce adapter
which gave it a really a really great
image actually the the old Nikon lens is
mixed with the the spinning glass and
the lettuce adapter kind of gave it this
really smooth kind of creamy filmic feel
which we really liked and we kind of
chose that camera partly because my DP
owned it but also partly because you
know back in 2009 when we shot the movie
DSLRs weren't really a mainstay of the
industry yet you know the 5d hadn't even
been out for a year and films like tiny
furniture which kind of opened the door
for using these DSLRs hadn't even come
out yet so we we kind of had sort of
limited options back then people were
kind of still using the kind of
traditional camcorders like the HDX is a
lot and so we kind of just used what we
had the change from when we made the
first movie until you know I'm about to
shoot my second film is like incredible
in terms of cameras I mean now you know
you can go to Best Buy you can buy a
$700 DSLR that shoots you know 4k and
you can shoot and pitch black whereas
back then it just simply wasn't the case
there was still like a lot of
limitations so it was just a completely
different landscape back then and so the
decision of what came we were gonna
shoot on this time was like a lot more
involved and we had a lot more options
and a lot more research to wait to do we
talked a lot about what we want the
image to look like for this film and we
also talked a lot about process you know
we're gonna be a really small nimble
crew and we're gonna be shooting pretty
quickly and so we didn't want to like
have to deal with a lot of peripheral
accessories that you need to add on to
it we didn't you know want a camera that
necessitated a huge camera department we
kind of wanted to be as agile and
adaptable as we possibly could my DP
Darren and I had shot a film on the
Blackmagic
Cinema Camera and we really liked how
that looked and we you know we liked
that the pocket Cinema Camera is really
small and it looks really great but you
know you kind of have to add all the
stuff to the camera
you know you the battery kind of sucks
you have to have an external power
source you know it's hard to do handheld
stuff with such a small camera so you
know you end up putting a cage and like
a shoulder rig so by the end of you know
adding all this stuff and all the
complications it's kind of as big and as
and as expensive is you know some of
these other cameras and so the camera
that we finally decided to shoot on was
the canon c300 you know I'd shot a music
video on it before and I just loved I
love the way it looks and I love
shooting with it I feel like it kind of
just takes all of the barriers out of
your way when you're shooting you know
it's really it's pretty like easy to use
it's really easy to get a great image
quality out of it the low-light is
incredible you can kind of go into
locations and not necessarily need to
light them too much which is a big part
of how we're gonna shoot this movie is
you know we're just gonna go into a lot
of you know rooms or businesses and try
to use as much natural and available
light as possible and the c300 is like
the best camera that I've ever used for
that kind of shooting you know I do I do
find myself going online and kind of
falling victim to the hysteria of of
camera culture that exists on there and
it's always these camera comparison
tests of like for some reason you know
guys shooting like the siding of their
house or like you know the blowing
leaves in their backyard to kind of show
you know the muddled compression of one
camera versus another or something like
that and at that point I find it good to
kind of step back and just remind
yourself of you know at the end of the
day we're supposed to be storytellers
and these cameras and tools and
technology that we use are just supposed
to be there in service of telling a
story and not just as like a cool toy to
have
even though I do find it shockingly easy
to kind of you know get swept up in the
debate of you know how many stops of
dynamic range something has and what is
the best codec and you know what bit
rates this kind of camera has but it is
always good to remind yourself to remind
myself that at the end of the day that
is not the most important thing it is
definitely important but it's not the
most important consideration when you're
making a movie